can you call up a ghost a deceased
person yeah no no you can't when we die
we go to one of two places dependent
upon your relationship with Jesus of
course
um so no and there's a great chasm in
between and of course the Bible tells us
that also if you look at Lazarus and the
rich man Luke 16 you'll see that there's
a great wall if you will Between Heaven
and Hell between so how I say it all the
time is I'm not bopping In and Out of
Heaven and coming to Earth and coming to
your dream talking to a psychic and
you're not getting out of hell and
coming here either so once we're the
Bible actually also says don't talk to
the sleeping they know nothing don't
talk to the dead they know nothing you
are where you are so you're never ever
contacting a deceased person you're
being duped but you're not being duped
because the psychic is trying to of
course minus the charlatans and
hucksters but people like me when I was
a real psychic medium I really wanted to
help people I was told I had a gift from
God